foreign
[Music]
good morning everybody uh type
JavaScript
how many of you are using typescript and
not JavaScript in their node code or
front-end code
perfect I use jstock typings but it's
like almost the same a lot of you
how many would wish not to need to
transpile the code that you're running
probably the same amount of hands raised
right so I'm going to talk about type
JavaScript this is a proposal for this
season and we're going to get into it
and what it's all about
um as I said it's a formal proposal for
enhancing JavaScript that will change
JavaScript development forever that's
that's my and it's a proposal for adding
types to JavaScript
uh a little bit about me I'm old like
80s old uh always will be a developer
what I love to do is code I'm currently
an architect at Round Forest we build
complex shopping sites but uh this is
more interesting I'm also a member of
the group that is writing the proposal
for tc39 and uh by faith and chance I'm
the original author
um little Dan uh approached me after I
wrote a blog post about j-stock typings
he corrected a few typos and a little
small mistakes and they said well I have
this idea
about a proposal and he talked to me
about it and I said oh yeah he said you
want to write it I know like a week
later it was written uh so I'm lucky to
be here and it's it's very exciting
because it's something that I've always
wanted to do and we'll talk about that
later why
um but I am one of the a group that is
doing this proposal writing this
proposal but the opinions are mine and
mine only and not necessarily all the
members of the authors of the world this
is the disclaimer definitely not my
employers and especially I do not speak
on behalf of the typescript team the
typescript team is part and and they are
on on board with this proposal but I do
not speak on behalf of them
also the proposal is officially part of
the tc39 process so whatever we say has
weight obviously but in the end it will
probably be different uh than than what
I'm showing you today so it's a long
process which we'll talk about in a
second so we don't know what's going to
be at the end of it
this talk will be about this proposal
where what is it and why was it proposed
so let's talk about the where
tc39 what is tc39 for people that do not
know it is it is the committee it's not
a committee there's the committee for
the standardization of JavaScript it's
called ecmascript for various legal
reasons thank you Oracle but uh but but
it's basically the the committee that
standardizes JavaScript and and
amazingly the process is very
transparent I go through all the meeting
notes I'm like one of those crazy uh and
and everything is written down all the
arguments all the discussions uh issues
in GitHub very very open very very
transparent feel free to go in there
um and each year they bring out a new
version of JavaScript and Echo script
2015 2016 2017 etc etc and with new
features basically uh array at a string
includes async away top level weight all
these kinds of things work come out of
the tc39 standardization process
and the process goes through a very
specific set of stages which I will talk
about uh stage zero is to be proposed um
it's a thing that we want to propose to
tc39 stage one is we the the T the
committee the committee meets I think
every two months something like that uh
and they listen to the proposals and
they if if they say yeah good idea then
it's stage one The Proposal doesn't have
to be like exact it can be like a rough
draft or or an idea but but enough so
that the committee can say yes it's a
good idea let's let's further go into
details stage two is where we go to the
the committee with a very very detailed
draft basically a spec uh and say this
this is what we want to do if they
accept it stage two if they don't back
to the drawing board we've seen these
things sometimes uh proposals reach
stage three and then go back back to
stage one and sometimes disappear
forever stage three is where we the all
the rough parts are are done every
little tiny bit of detail in the spec is
is cleaned up and it's waiting for
implementation when the committee says
to stage three then like webkit and V8
and JavaScript core and spider monkey
and and all those JavaScript runtimes uh
one to at least two of them I think I'm
not sure about the details need to
implement that feature and check that
it's fine
once the vendors uh um the the runtime
say that it is fine uh it gets to stage
four and that's part of the standard
okay
let's talk about what it is well first
of all it was proposed online on March
this year accepted to stage one which is
for great for me uh acceptance doesn't
mean that that's it it's going to be
part of the you know the standard just
means oh it's a good idea let's let's
discuss this further
let's talk about the proposal so this is
Javascript right regular JavaScript a
function ad that accepts two parameters
a plus b a can be a number a string an
object a function whatever if it works
it works if it doesn't it doesn't uh
um that's JavaScript for us
this if the proposal gets gets accepted
and I'm get I will probably get tired of
saying if this proposal gets accepted so
we'll assume that it is no no guarantees
obviously so for with this proposal this
will be uh um um um legal JavaScript so
a is a number B is a number and the
function returns a number you know this
from typescript or flow if you're using
flow uh type annotations
those are the type annotations which say
a is a number B is a number c is a
number will this path in in in in in the
future JavaScript uh if I say that a is
a number and I pass it a string somebody
has an idea will this pass
yes it's that's why it's true there the
second parameter it will pass because
the idea of type annotations is that
they are only annotations JavaScript
will not look at The annotation and try
and figure out whether uh the arguments
are legal or not the original name of
the proposal was types as comments so
you have the type annotations but
JavaScript will treat them as comments
so yeah treat the like comments and
what is the syntax of the types
the the the proposal says we don't care
this is legal it's not legal typescript
it's not legal flow I don't think
there's any type system out there that
it is legal in but it's legal it will be
legal JavaScript if this proposal is
accepted
um so the these areas
with the type annotations we call them
type annotation syntax space we will be
carving out
space in the JavaScript Syntax for type
annotations and for the JavaScript
runtime to ignore those type annotations
and we call them the type annotation 6
type space and when I go into detail
about the the the proposal I will talk
about all those type annotation syntax
spaces that are reserved for type
annotations
for example more type annotations like
type Foo equals function
return value etc etc those are more type
annotation syntax bases uh
obviously as you can see you probably
it's the same uh
syntax as typescript
so most legal typescript and flow and
Hegel by the way there are more type
systems out there than typescript and
and and flow uh
it's the same places so whatever a
typescript you have most of it will
will be legal JavaScript and obviously
this is not a coincidence those spaces
were chosen in this proposal so that
they can correspond
but this is not typescript this is not
flow this is not Hegel this will be
legal JavaScript this will not be legal
typescript
but what do I care if the type
annotations are ignored what do I get
okay why do I need type annotations and
the answer is there will still be
third-party type Checkers like
typescript flow Hegel and others that
will check your type annotations just
like eslint checks your code TSC or flow
will check your typescript type
annotations but JavaScript won't
JavaScript won't say that a variable is
unused okay but but yes lint will
JavaScript won't say that you're trying
to pass a string to something that
accepts a number but typescript will
during the build process
so summary of The Proposal we reserve
syntax space for type annotations they
are ignored by JavaScript runtime are
assumed to be checked by third-party
type Checkers like typescript and flow
and correspond to the same syntax space
the typescripts and flow and others use
roughly
so we announced the proposal on March
9th and and the internet exploded I've
never seen I've never seen a proposal
get this much uh
Twitter space if you want lots and most
of it was good lots of finally and yes
and you know those emojis uh but there
were lots of criticism mostly good
criticism some were well you know
Twitter uh
but but really mostly mostly good
criticism and and the issues in GitHub
are are fine and there's lots of
discussions there
um and I want to address those
criticisms in this talk and and show why
we chose the path we chose
so let's talk about the why why are
types at all
this is It's a good question a lot of
people ask that it is not a trivial
feature to add to JavaScript it's not
like uh you know whatever a string dot
include obviously for a feature of this
size the benefits have to be substantial
and I give two graphs
as an answer it's actually two graphs
and a half this is the number of PRS in
March 2022. notice JavaScript and
typescript
typescript it has almost been the almost
the same number of PRS as JavaScript
the JavaScript Community is and we've
seen this is using typescript heavily
today so they are using types they are
used in the field and have proven the
value obviously if they have not proven
the value then people wouldn't use them
we're not dumb
state of JavaScript 2020 static typing
is the most requested feature
state of JavaScript 2021 static typing
is the most requested feature and if
you're still not convinced this is from
this month
remember typescript was almost the
number of PRS was almost like JavaScript
well this month typescript passed
JavaScript in the number of PRS in
GitHub which is amazing uh so ah I don't
know people want types in JavaScript
they just so is it worth the complexity
I'd say Obviously yes
three more reasons not to add types of
Dubsteps and we'll go through each of
them types are difficult for beginners
to grasp
valid criticism JavaScript is simple
simple for Developers
yes but my daughter she's she's 15 years
old she's starting to learn
um
uh computers uh programming and she
started with well Java
sorry but but yeah not not a good
starting language but but but she's fine
she understands types she's using type
she gets it it's not that difficult yes
if you're starting to learn JavaScript
and you've already learned JavaScript
and then
adding types after the fact then that
that becomes more complex but if this
proposal gets accepted types will
already be a part of how people use
JavaScript initially so I don't think
they will add bigger complexity and in
the GitHub issues I discussed this there
was a teacher uh which says which said
new programmers searching for example
code are likely to find typescript and
flow examples and then Wonder wide
results in an error when viewed in the
browser so people copy paste code put
them in the console or the node Rebel
and it doesn't work and they don't
understand why beginners don't forget
so this is this is this is good I like
that in other words we're mounted or not
type annotations are everywhere so
beginners need to learn them
this this one's really weird types most
of them are good I I don't get this
types increase the payload in web apps
of course types make your code larger
so do comments
so does indentation
do we want to get rid of indentation do
we want to get rid of comments no do we
want to get rid of type annotations just
because they make the payload larger no
why don't we because we have minifiers
remember those where they can Minify the
code remove the type annotations and
work good so type annotations in
development don't need to be removed no
need for minifiers when you get to
production just run the minifier and
you're done
this is one is good I used to be there I
don't like types types are shite
I I have I have a I have a colleague of
mine who was there in in the days of of
when I thought just like that
even if I asked about that now today
types of shy uh it's not about me
it's about you it's about the community
and the community wants types so it
doesn't really matter what I think or he
or he thinks or she thinks or they think
what matters is what the community think
and the community as I've shown in the
graphs wants types
okay so you want type annotations but
we already have typescript why do we
need to extend JavaScript and this is
this is a good question well most of
them are good except the payload thing
why not just continue using tooling
there are three answers of philosophical
pragmatical and political
people I come from the 90s I come from
the 80s we have forgotten Our Roots in
scripting write code run it write code
run it we especially in in front end we
go through this lengthy build process
and and we transpile and we do Source
Maps which never really work and we add
complexity and complexity and complexity
on it we have become addicted to tooling
we cannot not use it anymore
Junior developers don't understand how
this tooling Works they don't they don't
understand the build process especially
in front end but also in back end
senior developers don't understand
seriously nobody understands uh that's
why we have created react app and remix
and next and all that because we don't
want to understand it but it's there and
when it goes wrong and when we need to
like combine it with other stuff it gets
hairy
tooling is now basically what I think
cargo called it used to be very
important guarantee but today I don't
think it's necessary anymore it's still
necessary for production builds
obviously but it incurs tremendous run
uh development time overhead and
complexity
philosophical answer
people is Javascript is the only
language where we're coding in one
language typescript and Flow
and we're running it in another
that doesn't happen in Python that
doesn't happen in Ruby that doesn't
happen in Java well sort of uh there's a
growing Rift between the code that we
write and the code the tc39 standardizes
and that is not good we need to mend
that Rift we need to bring these two
languages together
and and and the pragmatic answer
not the philosophical is is typescript
come on it's everywhere all modern
tooling if you think about eslint and
minifiers and whatever tooling you're
using they must understand typescript
syntax today think of es build and all
that everybody now understands
typescript and that is not good because
typescript evolves
and they need to keep track of that and
and and not only that typescript now has
a monopoly in type systems if I wanna I
I had a lunch uh discussion if I want to
build a pipe system today I can't
because you know that competes or or
works with typescript or extends
typescript I can't do that typescript or
flow I can't do that because the
Monopoly
this proposal simplifies the tool in
tremendously
so and and the political answer too is I
think tc39 should be or the arena for
enabling type systems that will be
almost in everyone's dress code in the
future
okay so we want types to be part of the
language but this will not enable us to
standardize types in the future people
got that very quickly because JavaScript
has to be Backward Compatible and if
we're saying we're ignoring content type
annotations we will need to ignore them
for for now and for the future
true
but when the need arises you know love
will find a way we will find a way if we
want to standardize type systems we will
find a way
um
we'll figure it out why stop it ignoring
type annotations this goes the other way
okay let's do it the other way as long
as we're doing types why not Embrace
typescript syntax
um and the answer is Microsoft and
Facebook with flow and other type
systems want to continue you know
experimenting there in that area
standardizing it will stop them in their
tracks and we don't want that we want
them to continue experimenting types in
JavaScript are not done
um so that's why I don't want to embrace
that way we don't want to embrace and we
want to continue experimenting with
other type systems I just saw esnol
which is really interesting people want
to if if this proposal gets people will
want other type systems
and the other one is typescript is huge
standardizing it will never never ever
end
the option is build a type system of our
own you have two options here cleaner
and simpler
um
a lot of people say oh typescript is too
complicated let's make a simple one but
the reason typescript is complicated is
because JavaScript types and typing is
complicated
for example pick you want this code pick
to show an error there because pick
chooses creates an object only based out
of A and B okay A type system that
enables that is very very complex
enables other stuff too so typescript is
complicated for a reason
the other one is it's too complicated
let's make it cleaner like Haskell and O
camel in reason but that won't work
because JavaScript you need to change
JavaScript to have it be a cleaner type
system and you can't shave jobs from
JavaScript
the third argument is well let's go all
the way let's do runtime type checking
this is an interesting option uh there
have uh
um some uh sorry
um
if you think about it
most static languages today do not do
runtime type checks C plus plus doesn't
do runtime picks JavaScript doesn't do
runtime type tricks they do but in the
like right in the edge
all the type tracking is done in the
compiler not in the runtime it's it's
interesting to think about that
having said that tc39 said that we
should check this aspect of this
proposal
another one is let's optimize based on
types I know that a accepts a number
that function accepts a number I can
optimize the code the the runtime and
the answer I'm not is is probably not
there's a Twitter
um discussion on that from Mathias
binance I hope I'm correct I'm saying it
correctly uh on why this will never be
feasible in JavaScript as it is today
okay I'll skip the summary because I
want to talk about the proposal as I
said caveat this will undergo
considerable change it's just a first
draft but let's talk about what what
what it is function a this is in
functions we have type annotations for
parameters and for the return value
big question where does the pipe end how
does the JavaScript know what to ignore
and and in comments it's easy when you
you look at a slash star uh you'll you
you you find the the stock star slash at
the end that's the comment how do we
know where a type ends we can delimit by
comma
like okay when's the next parameter
because there can be a comma inside the
type
okay we we want we wanted to deal with
that and the answer we found and again
this can change is
we search for the comma
but we if there are parentheses like uh
angle brackets or square brackets or
parentheses or that we we count them and
balance them and ignore anything in
between those balanced parentheses okay
that takes care of 90
five percent of pipes in typescript the
others where this doesn't work if you
take typescript code today then you just
surround them with parentheses and
actually it actually it's valid
typescript so some amount of change in
typescript will need to be done but this
can be a code mod very very easily a
code modification
and this will allow continued evolution
of the types without breaking JavaScript
because typescript and flow and others
can build inside that space very easily
okay so functions variables definition
of variables types we know this from
typescript and flow interface from
typescript and flow or maybe just
typescript not sure class properties
uh generics very important obviously uh
importing and exporting types are
supported in this proposal there are
things that aren't
oh wait uh the way there are things that
are like what do we do now is is as
because flow in typescript have
different Syntax for for typecasting
generic function and vocation this is
interesting why is genetic function
invocation a problem because uh it's not
valid JavaScript the less than
JavaScript treated as a less than and
not as a generic function communication
we're thinking about dealing with that
this parameters I don't want and
declarations which should be in DTS
files anyway function overloads which
typescript and flow allow what do we do
with that I don't know we'll think about
something abstract classes may have
runtime semantics
uh member modifiers public read-only etc
etc maybe we're thinking about using a
single or sigil never know how to say
that percent public percent read only to
say just ignore those
um and typescript type they will not be
in the spec um I passed the time I'll
try enum's name faces and primary
properties these are typescript
constructs that create JavaScript code
they're not just erased from the code
okay
um and and we're not going to support
that and jsx because well that's not
typed
the consequences if this proposal ends
no more transpilation of most of
typescript and flow with real browser
esm we will be able to finally remove
all touring during tooling during Dev
that's my my hope uh this will still be
checked by third-party type Checkers
slow convergence of incompatible
typescript and flow to the new syntax
like the minor incompatibilities tooling
will become much simpler and other type
systems hopefully and probably will be
experimented with
but it will take time
it will take years not months years and
I think
it will be worth the wait and thank you
very much
[Applause]